oh dude that was a fake cazza macca play
[ __ ] off dude that's a thick it might
have only one then when I here's I check
if it's safe and markiplier nice alright
we ready for this Oh
once again huh
Swedish meatball catch it
I've been trained in the Viking arts of
a [ __ ] fur
but I don't see how they should throwing
nades
[Music]
take that date advice oh my god not the
Hat
ah my last one
yes
surprised you thought you could beat me
if you thought you could beat me I'm
[ __ ] poet yeah yeah well what does
this yeah too strong for this game
giving him in freelance uh what we got
in here like you don't escape from me no
one escapes me no one no one do you
understand
absolutely nobody I'm actually part
chicks ice
[Laughter]
[Music]
Emily you know I need those I need it I
need it more of you and you call me
[ __ ] now we got more battles coming
make the [ __ ] up samurai
we got a city to burn Hey look christmas
comes early hey where's miss gams barely
a boy I thought was only January [ __ ]
hey hello hey son hey careful careful
don't go please whatever you do
you don't use that thinner
dad mother mother
flipping over turn alright I have to go
in there
can i no I don't think I can fit in
there can i push this I gotta crawl this
game okay how do I get in there huh I
don't get in there I took me way too
long there I'm sorry guys
Hey ah it's alright I got plenty ho hey
hey alright
some helpful to actually begin all right
let's not make the same mistake twice
are you kidding me I can use the
multi-tool are you serious whatever do
with this
oh this is spooky nice okay so that's
how you do it that's why they kill you
even though you're super far away that's
all right I take the long way
oh dude this is [ __ ] I do have to fart
but I've been holding it in for you
gamers my god
this place is a goddamn deaf man one
wrong move one more move and it could
all be over that is clearly not how I
challenge all right what I do wrong
oh it's safe I feel good
Denning in and in in it I know that I
wouldn't so good
[Music]
okay okay I'll get it I'll get it now
because I'm a gamer gamer gets the
ladies first
everyone OSIS goddamn this at workout
and I we did it
this place has been cleansed and we are
safe
indeed yes yes what do I go where did
you come from where to go where do you
come from Papa Nambu Skiba pepper pepper
a a hasta la vista doxa haruka-san oh my
god
yeah I see them but I want them oh never
mind of this I'll just go and get them
I'll just go and get them gamers damn
I'm rich alright bring me to the action
I want to murder people that's the fun
stuff oh my god don't jump
I'm guessing I why are they a bunch of
them here there has to be that yet no
hey thanks
just [ __ ] are you doing it can't hit me
yeah
- easy [ __ ] fight like you made
that [ __ ] fight like you mean it mother
you guys seem like a bunch of little
[ __ ] like I wonder where - [ __ ] it
think I don't see you over there you
think I don't see you over there
I get the aim of an eagle eye all right
stop it you think I don't see you
oh yeah I got your friend hostage he's
still alive you know he could still make
it if you come out with your I think not
thought I think not what is this place
anyway
Oh Russell doesn't like vodka yeah I
knew you were rich there's some good
[ __ ] my man whatever
I'm strong enough I don't you I just
don't want it I just don't want it
oh my god finally
I really have to [ __ ]
to be fair I can't go up there but let's
go up here first
yeah all right it's fine keep your
secrets all right so this is clearly a
all right we just got push this off yeah
that's what I wanted you are correct did
it fall in between I got to crawl now
what is this game just gonna just get a
push seven you're standing on sand no
Anna Turner crusher crusher
Hey look what the bucket
like with the bucket brought in huh the
whole game just sounds different
markiplier don't do it don't do it mark
play I thought I try to tell him yeah my
little child there's a thing in front of
him I see it we'll get it later we'll
get it later aligator GamersGate I hate
it
it's very through beliefs before I think
it is bleach bleach for are you where
are you you have to go we have to go
[ __ ] don't ever hurt my child my
baby I'll see one thing at a time
oops
[Music]
you're so cute hey this is Inga and this
is been a big event look at you you're
so cute
shut up go alright you're going back in
for now you did not have to do it like
all that make you outside so I can scare
me there
but looks isn't fair and combine
barricades up ahead is stopping anyone
from getting any closer to the vault
okay
[Music]
make your way into the distillery and
see where it takes you my truck back
online with fire aah oh wow hey Emma I'm
not very good at aiming with these you
think I'm afraid you think I'm afraid
Jesus
catch this too easy too easy
[Music]
[ __ ] the bad is your general all
of you
yeah yeah I'm number War I training all
the ancient wisdom in arts you can't
[ __ ] with me
you can't walk what man what's making us
sound
that's where you put the battery Oh God
this bed never get it from here is it
hard to be a little bit
[Music]
that's it hurt that all you all your
friends look Jake sighs take this all
your friends will die
[Music]
too easy too easy I pulled out my
headphones again for the 500th [ __ ]
time I've done it I should know by now
just stop doing it alright we're almost
there almost there gamers any time now
[ __ ] any time [ __ ]
okay
and just like that he was that Queen the
Queen all right finally we can use this
do I need to put this new battery in
maybe maybe that's what anything turns
out I can't think of 3d gamers life
comes at you that fast
there's a lot of effort just to access
upgrades in my opinion sure let's try it
maybe it's really good
come on let missing one recen okay so
now we have power
maybe we can redistribute it yeah yeah
that's what I wanted to do all right do
we finally have power I think so please
just [ __ ] work
so the green one has power now so we
probably have to reroute it from here oh
you better [ __ ] die sad
yeah funky on the pepper board had
safety first then I extend my and I
drank it ROG it goes to the skies no I
had it I had it let me jump in Sweden
[ __ ] all right I got this new
gun I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
hello hello who's here put the pies
gonna [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
Jeff manemma Jeff Jeff Jeff where is he
where is it
are you Jeff are you Jeff dokoni the sky
chef sir don't go near a monster Jeff
Sam yeah
oh nasty are you doing ba all right we
got the force field all right can you
stop they're not stopping what if I
tickle you guys do stuff then it's one
of this thing we have to yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I found your weakness
cool that's how we're doing it that's
how we're doing it now
[Music]
I'm trying to open you
Jeff where are you Jeff hello my name is
Jeff goddamnit
he must be here somewhere
I can smell this beautiful soul can I
a garments accommodates I got would
forget fluffy new situation here you
talking to me know how you pay back
you keep your tongue to yourself and I
don't shoot you in it by what the hell
was that but does that Jeff don't worry
you can't see Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff
Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff
yeah
now damn you look good Chapel hey Jeff
you like wine
hey Jeff you like vodka dumb he dumb
all right Jeff see you later
ain't got time ain't for this I can
finish this right dude
that's a little tiger
how do I know there's a door there Jeff
Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff hey those
things are nasty you gotta cover your
mouth
thanks Alex I'm Larry nice to meet you
Jerry killed whoops
Larry's Mary Emma right hey come to me
you're mine now your mind what gain my
hand pitches in my saying I don't know
Oh put the hand you think is Mickey
mark that I have to remove this first
safety first gamers yeah this is really
cool actually I just want to [ __ ] with
Jeff you know I'm saying are you Jeff
you [ __ ] with Jeff
[Music]
yeah make him come to you dumbass what
get here dude what the hell that [ __ ]
hurt
dumbass you're so dumb I bet your mom
was dumb to like little dummy dummy
family family faith made of dummies
dummies I miss my man my tummy goes
yummy dummy emitter madam LM a Jeff your
mom's a little bit Oh Oh God
Jeff Jeff Jeff you've that man me
man yeah oh you stink though you stank
talk for real though for real for real
this [ __ ] bow then I got more vodka
are we just going here okay we are back
oh my god I cannot tell you how surreal
it is to watch my own video and then to
enter the game yourself like that's cool
one day you're you're watching Jay says
[ __ ] you I'm dead
it's I'll freeze I'll freeze the time
yes freeze are you kidding me
all right we just got the vodka all
right in there's the vodka hey Jeff hey
Jeff over there
oh he smell oh he makes tea should I try
and close the door I closed the door now
bye bye Jeff door is closed
door is closed [ __ ] you Jeff
suck my Jeff yeah yeah yeah suck it Jeff
you betta just learn your betta just
realize you're a hater Jeff no one likes
you you were aborted I mean you're what
it's called you're an orphan no you're
you know what I'm trying to call you
Jeff just understand that you are what
I'm calling you it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter alright let me get one of
these for safety cuz I have a feeling
it's gonna all smell like ass oh Jesus
now my headphones every time every
goddamn time these [ __ ] headphones
I hate Don I hate headphones I love them
buy them though check it out they're
actually really good
don't drop the thing now I gotta make
sure I don't drop in when I hit
cool alright well you can't hurt me
because nothing that isn't real can't
tired to me then oh they make sounds so
I gotta make sure I don't is he gonna
come or what Aaron's then I thought for
sure I was gonna read there anything
electricity and that's what I thought
that's what we're doing here
mmm I miss it what am I missing that's
so [ __ ] obvious what is this hey
babies how you doing
all right so anything else it's weird
when they goes in the wall I'm like
stinky stinky stinky you're really gonna
do me like that
you're really gonna do me like that Jeff
hey Jeff
give it up simple that's right I call
you Sepp do I have to go in there is
that what's happening Jeff we're cool
right yeah we're cool we're definitely
cool let me just put this down Hey look
at that
oh my god oh why did I just hit what I
just hit
Jeff you're weak you're pathetic you're
not good not gonna love Jeff all right
when your necks actually explore her
we're here
I see I just want to make sure I don't
miss any Reston's because I got eagle
eyes I got eagle eyes everywhere I see
you mr. vodka man huh no what's a vodka
breath here Cheers
oh look at that and just like that he
found everything in the game okay
now the puzzle I think we have to let
him in because otherwise this would be a
boring game so I'm just gonna do that
but I want it to be known mr. Jeff I'm
not doing this
we just got to make sure we do not yeah
I want to make sure I have a vodka on me
every time because I I don't like being
scared very much that's not my thing
place you down there definitely gonna
set something up where like you
accidentally knock one over I'm sure of
it yeah look at that
I'm not falling for your tricks
you really do me like that you really do
me like that game
you're blind Jeff you're blind you drank
too much alcohol do you understand and
you stay you smell like ass I'm trying
to throw it about you there we go Nikol
did you not hear that alright just duck
just duck just duck bro
just duck bro just duck bro oh he's sad
look at him he's sad and pathetic babe
he's sad and pathetic
he's our Jefferson simple guys whoo what
a thought see they did me like that I
knew they'd do me like that
Jeff do not come back he's stinky I'm
solving puzzles here baby baby baby Jeff
go home you're drunk I did it Jeff I did
it Jeff
[Music]
Jeff I got vodka for rebuff oh yes we
can be cool I'm not afraid of you Jeff
I'm not afraid of the future
hey Jeff hey Lee smell he smells Oman he
smell each mouth he'd smelled a la vodka
ah very good very good vodka all right
let's look for stuff what do we got
maybe I'm but here excuse me Jeff he
used a guy Jeff he's my guy I love him I
love him so much
it's gotta make sure he doesn't sneak up
on it
did I do something bad here oh you can't
come in beta all right so hold up Jeff I
need one second from you buddy
just give me a minute here all right
this is what happens when you're told
Jeff where do I direct it
it goes in the wall Jeff I hold ah
excuse me
ah there we go I did it okay we're stuck
here together oh my god sorry
how am I supposed to do then maybe I was
too loud oh it was a good it was because
I wasn't covering my mouth
I bet it
you want some beans brother that's beans
pick the beans
what's happening
[Applause]
oh my doggies crazy in there I would
rather get him suck in that oh I would
rather have Jeff suck in the elevator to
be honest that's probably what I would
do in this in there how you doing man
yeah hey Jeff watch this you'll love
this now all right that's cool
sarin or three though that means epic in
Russian I'm still alive
Jeff you don't care anymore did he lost
oh God
Kove fee Oh coffee I read something in
Russian
that means anal okay oh yeah
got to make sure I cover my mouth Jeff
what happen to you you'll really this is
what happens when you become a Coomer
just look at him okay okay we're going
here
we're sneek is that a flipping insect
arm there hello Jeff
you got to see this Jeff you gotta see
this
Jeff Jeff not so closely see you you
haven't showered in years it's
disgusting
I'm gonna open this door but I'm not
actually okay I'm actually not gonna go
in there what's my plan anyway
whoa this is so pretty
ah Jeff you can't come here oh this is
bad
that's right that's right hey Jeff beans
beans [ __ ] hey Jeff it's just your
girlfriend huh it's just your girlfriend
hey
sayonara Jeff sir
daisuki this oh no that's right Jeff
doesn't understand the worse he is
coming oh that's right Jeff doesn't
understand doors get out of my way babe
don't you dare touch the vodka this is
weird man it's gonna get Miguel don't
hurt me
can I move these boxes without pissing
off Jeff yeah if you understand
we're sleepwalking there's a box there
Muricy I don't like the fact that I
can't see him no I mean hey look I'm up
here Jeff I'm gonna put him on a
flipping world what am i keep touching
stuff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff
chapter two chapter after Jeff Jeff Jeff
Jeff Jeff do juju jr. Jeff dude Savion
bro 1969 fine year Jeff you would like
this we could be Bros you know we don't
have to fight is there anything else I
don't know where he is I'm just gonna do
that see if I can find him hmm ketchup
from 1942
Jeff if you weren't such a guy if you
weren't such am I too big I'm too big
for this game I'm gonna spider my jump
and I'm risking them all right I look
cool like you don't see I put up my arm
like this and then I jump down so it's
like you see what I mean
like that's cool all rights go in here
this is cozy
this looks like how female decorates
their houses with like fairy lights and
stuff this is what girls like isn't it
stop it you're gonna give away my
location oh I see a resin in there
shut up nipple-twisters I want the rest
yeah yeah yeah all right get them oh
don't bite me all right got my kitchen
we're good
what this days see what I see is see
what I mean girls love this [ __ ] Oh
it's a push stop it I know Jeff is gonna
have a problem that he loves this place
with the help something else explode
all right spider-man Jim just imagine
that I look really cool okay you're
gonna have to use your imagination
imagine
hey buddy hey you come with me shotgun
Jeff Jeff's just [ __ ] off dude
[Music]
all right what do we got we gotta get
three batteries and we got to mess with
Jeff he didn't hear me jump idiot
I thought he could hear well that was
like Jeff's only good quality was that
he heard really well oh no is there
anything I can you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
almost let me out good thing I brought a
bottle of champagne with me am i right
gamers Oh careful gas mask perfect yeah
you got nothing on here now there
nothing on me Oh someone likes barrels a
bit much hey I'm not judging come on man
wake up pathetic dude jib that's jib in
Russian
Jeb my mind keeps twisting itself hey
you're not allowed in here it's 18 plus
oh my I just punched something I don't
know what I punched oh I know why my
because I'm standing in front of a
mirror I think probably shouldn't have
dropped that should I
Jeff I found the battery get Jeff we're
good right cheers to you Jeff
drink every time I say Jeff Jeff Jeff
Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff
you don't my speech nothing's you scared
ain't afraid of you Jeff ain't afraid of
you Jeff man pathetic pathetic man all
right we did it
that's the Bama Ram in my ham on lamb
BAM slam
cheers to Jeff from a chance to him what
a [ __ ] I gotta go back to Jeff guys
this is a spooky area of the game isn't
it it's always scary being followed
especially in VR I don't like yeah I
don't like it never gets old
go away I'm not gonna pay this month
rent the absurd they have snapped gun
they have snuffed gun all right
not everyone likes it that's it in the
quiet taste it's a good brand let's make
sure we don't walk in the same direction
as Jeff I think that generally helps all
right yeah I'm good I'm good we're doing
good right yeah I think we're quite a
team I think we're getting there but I
am I mean you're the doctor boys find it
be good boo boo I'm trying to be I'm
trying to be responsible here guys
trying to do a good job there's a
flipping wheel for that one this is
ridiculous I'll put you down but don't
worry I'm not gonna hurt you
flipping wheel for this one dude
flipping wheel Jeff can you go away I'm
doing something
yes
am i wearing one already
I think they expire after a while sorry
s alright yes I I know how to do this
Jeff hold up different it's like pulling
it's like pulling uh and it's like
pulling uh yeah look at that
it's alright no it's over there don't do
it Felix
do not do it oh my god
worth it we gotta rest in worth it worth
it every time all right so I gotta bend
this right I just gotta grab it and put
it on it
through there oh that's so cool all
right let's not make too much sound
watch me not hit a single one that's how
strong my arms are do you understand now
how the hell does that work this makes
no sense at all Jeff can you come and
explain this for me please I don't know
how this puzzle works I'm a gay arms
girl Mexican can you go farther away
like that way thank you don't maze
[ __ ] [ __ ] come on I'm out of I'm
out of vodka legit like Hecky not oh
never mind don't do it I did it anyway
all right we got to whoa chance to unite
way [ __ ] dinner I'm not chase to
unite there's got to be the third one
here and though it's just arresting is
that worth it
I got a question if this like it's worth
a one recen right I don't think it was I
really think that's it
that's my cue of not anything worth in
Maine it ain't worth it let me work it I
could put it here but I can also throw
it don't like the ladder sorry guys yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff
Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff is that
Jeff Jesus Jeff
there's a bug guy like what is this oh
my god it's the lion
insects right
no no no okay I don't think there's a
battery here I think this is where I
start the actual thing all right there's
one more to find let's go get it let's
go get it gamers so I'm gonna I'm gonna
leave you here don't don't be scare
safer here you're safer here miss I need
another vodka in my inventory
do you understand you can't come here
right what's the matter
I just need more vodka that's nothing to
judge about that right [ __ ] you made it
wrong
Jeff you're not allowed on my birthday
party you're not invited
everyone's gonna be there everyone that
is something at least but you wouldn't
know anything about that would you Jeff
I bet your penises are so small you
can't even see it without going into
space and using the Hubble telescope
that's how tiny look at the eye look at
that [ __ ] guy what are you doing stop
it
get some help have some month gun on me
breath
all right Jeff listen this is my last
time I'm coming down there you have to
understand you can't keep being like
this where is he
Jeff did this piece actually oh that's
bad I thought I had a gas mask mama that
bat bat bat bat bat bat better there but
but but but all right it's in here isn't
it yeah I see you ah yeah I got it
that's not where I want him
Oh
yeah Jeff I got it that freaking got it
dude that's so Jeff are you it's not
it's not listening to me
have you not been paying attention Jeff
there's two people in the relationship
you understand that right
you have to talk to each other you have
to love each other really I did not make
a sound
I better not die here oh no oh no all
right one last chance to you make one
last bond by ash or everyone as we say
in Sweden
au revoir better eat ass [ __ ] all right
let's go Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff
ja ja ja ja that's what I'm talking
about that's what I'm talking about
Superman jump yeah wow that was cool
that was cool feel good about that we
did it guys we did it oh my god
he's sleeping I'm feeling that's not
that last of Jeff never stinking
stinking sensation then Jeff's gonna
come back when we least expect it oh how
about that here
whoa dude Jeff there's a Tumnus over
there it's over there
all right we're done we're done yes
you lost admit defeat
and say that's not walking us that way
he went that way
he went that way he went that way
he went that way one inch F way tell me
why Jeff it surely is not working
I need something straight sadena Jeff
you're an alcoholic stopping your
friends and family are concerned
where's power coming from
I found all the resin wrestling there's
mine you can adopt me the resin admire
all right I'm gonna I want you to skid
out over have you seen treatment
one by a Schmo
hey hey
do the Japs under there a bit he there's
no ways there's no way that's no way
what
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god it's arresting in here Jeff
Jeff did you find any resting in that
for me Mike
Jeb you look good you look good not come
on life you okay yeah Jeff yeah don't
that was my joke
certainly wrestling in here legit I hear
it it makes that sound doesn't it it's
fine never been better all right oh my
god
[Music]
we could
well absolutely fried a ball great also
little heads-up I think the tunnel is
full of Van Lines just in case I cut out
permanently
I'm on aunt line you know aliens with
stabby legs
oh god antlion
that's alright it's alright I fired off
a mini antlion
to the game it's pretty spooky this is
some scary [ __ ] dude